hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's now the last day of week two in
fortnight Chapter two season two and a
bunch of new map updates have landed if
you're new around here this is the
series where we look through all map
changes no matter how small they are so
sit your butt down for 10 minutes use
cold atom arrow in the shop to keep this
series going and let's go through
everything that happened to the map in
the last seven days by the way if you
come back here weekly you should totally
subscribe it will be much appreciated it
really would come on come join team
thick
[Music]
where shall we start let's go up and
check on our Lord and Savior Graham the
genome at his radio station he is still
here and the first of a series of
changes has happened right here the
former shack which then became a gang
hideout now has a helipad just like
those seen at the grotto yacht and rig
what could this mean
my guess is these will either become a
fast travel point where your team will
get through the chopper and quickly
choose another location that would be
pretty epic and those people who want
more movement in the game will be happy
too or maybe this will be for an LTM
like the old getaway game do you
remember when we had to get to the
floating vans in the sky but now it
could be a chopper instead let me know
your thoughts let's see who calls this
right
last week I missed something monumental
thousands of you told me about a cabin
in the woods with a surprise in sight so
off I ventured to see what all the fuss
was about
and oh my god I'm glad you told me the
secret entrance to an underground
facility and lo and behold who was there
the misfits plotting to overruled Graham
the genome the last time we saw these
guys was at wintertime when Santa's
Teddy's crashed a truck and began their
uprising plotting in private that day I
thought I rid the world of this tyranny
but I guess I was wrong but wait there's
more down here they have a prisoner
another gnome he definitely needs a name
and that's where you come in what shall
we name Graham's twin brother Graham the
genome and hmm the genome it's up to you
I'll be stocking in the comments to find
his new name until then we'll leave him
in the bunker and watch from the shadows
the misfit known war has only just begun
remember the chair truck we've been
following for seemingly forever well
this week it has moved once again
starting off at the docks the chairs
moved inland to the first bridge and
then the gas station a little further
down the road while check where it is
right now heading into retail row could
we see a new store created for these
one-of-a-kind limited-edition
brand-new antique chairs we shall see
there was also another flatbed truck we
saw move last week over by the nursery a
pallet filled truck completely cut up
the timber truck on its way forward and
right now that vehicle has reached all
the way to the outskirts of misty
[Music]
hello there could this truck be going
over to retail row to create a new store
or will this be the start of a new hot
watch because now is the time epic I
have t-shirts ready for the second
coming of hot watch
I don't really maybe I should do that
anyway let's keep an eye on this our
next changes are the start of something
new jumping over to house watch no no we
don't do that anymore
just outside a clearing has been made
what could this be
in future weeks one thing that gives it
away right away is the wind sock this
shows us that air speeds are important
so most likely this will be yet another
helipad and whilst we're doing this
remember the cabin over by Holly hedges
it was suddenly revamped overnight well
the same thing is happening right there
right now a new clearing with basic
supplies this has to be another helipad
right
looks like fast travel is gonna be a
real thing soon I can't wait but please
epic pretty please epic don't add
rockets to the choppers
I still have PTSD from playing call of
duty
[Music]
are you ready for two of the most
important map changes ever seen I mean
these are huge these are mind-blowing
these are humongous get yourself over to
the Iron Man rowdy roddy piper man who
sits over on the mountain looking out to
sea can you see the change
yeah his his head is slightly moved but
now he spots something in the distance
he sat he had dormant for months with
the only update a pair of glasses he got
at Christmastime well now he sprang into
life if you find what the hell he's
looking at please let me know another
change can be found at Ferris Bueller's
house let's go back in time on day 1 of
chapter 2
this house was spotted with a sports car
in the garage later in the season the
car somehow fell and smashed onto the
beach below I couldn't help myself I
blamed the ginger ninja bread man Wow
what right now the car is being rescued
from the beach by this hulking great
monstrosity
can you guess what will happen next will
we see the car loaded up and sent to
lazy Lake to be repaired if it does epic
please give me a job I really think I
could do map changes for a living pretty
please nope oh well help me out with
this one last week when the grotto
arrived can you confirm something for me
did it always have I hose like a skull
shape I can't believe I never noticed
this in week one and wanted to
double-check that it's always been there
am I going crazy
probably our man time Oh going back to
where the chuck chuck trap going back to
where the chair trunk is did you know
the building nearby has a secret cellar
there's only one chest down here but hey
it's a map change so it deserves a
mention
crazy mother
over the last week many of you have told
me about other small changes in the
world such as secret files and suitcases
to have been spotted so far and I'm sure
you guys will find more this week the
first is found by salty springs just
outside is a fast food truck venture
over to find a secret file and suitcase
nearby another has been found north of
the farm by the lawnmower race track do
you agree that we definitely need lawn
mowers as a mode of transport in
fortnight how cool would that be anyway
I digress just buy the SEAT beyond here
you'll find more spy files and goodies a
great addition I was told about just
after last week's episode can be found
up by the shark look around in the air
vents and you'll find the little fungus
beings starting to spread away from the
shanty islands and engulf the shark
these ones seem immune so to take them
out and eradicate them you just take
down the entire air vent good riddance I
need a dad joke here I need a mushroom
dad joke I didn't want to break up this
party I thought I was a fun guy nope
okay sorry
[Music]
a few of the things people asked me to
comment on are the rooms at the ghost
and shadow locations mainly the ones on
the rig so that's what we'll do now we
have a nod back to season 4 of chapter 1
and the superhero theme we all loved and
look at the wall there is the mask from
the Green Lantern there's also a special
weapon here and many people are
theorizing this weapon is foreshadowing
a sci-fi themed LTM using weapons from
save the world in the very next room we
can see a weapon being built from
blueprints which backs this up can you
imagine an LT and we save the world
weapons it would be insanely good and
you know which member of team dick is in
save the world penny for your thoughts
and finally over on spawn island have
you visited the secret bunker under the
main watchtower is a vent which leads to
this epic place complete with sleeping
arrangements and one big-ass computer
it's another place I believe will leave
us clues in the days and weeks to come
so keep dropping in and let me know if
you find any changes here my twitter
handle is adam grenade and my DMS are
always open for map changes and lookie
here it's another one of those files
will these become important I can't wait
to find out
so that's where we are at the end of
week 2 chapter 2 season 2 to be
continued
as always here are some of the gorgeous
people who have used cold and amaru in
the shop you know it I'm gonna say every
week I really appreciate you if you
don't see your name here don't worry
I either haven't seen your DM yet or
your name will be in the myth chasers
video coming at the weekend
if I get edited in time thanks for your
time everyone it's been an absolute
pleasure I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade and you're awesome see ya
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]